when I left the theater after watching
James White I needed at least five
minutes to regroup because it affected
me and I felt that I was not alone there
were definitely people that I could kind
of just feel that they needed some time
and there's been just a handful of
movies that have done that to me maybe
21 grams invisible war for the two of
you personally what movies as a patron
as a viewer have had the same that's an
on-the-spot question question I feel
like you know one of the things is the
the way a movie hits you or a play or
whatever hits you while it's happening
and and when it's over that you're kind
of unable to move forward right away but
to me and an equally important or maybe
even more important measure is how long
a film lives with you afterwards
so you know I saw it on television I
can't even imagine if I'd seen it in a
movie theater but I finally saw
Clockwork Orange this year you know and
I have to say that's a very you know I
know everyone's seen it now and it's old
news but to me who had never seen it
before
it's so shocking and it's so frightening
and it just you know it still lives
inside my head as a just a terrifying
futuristic nightmare I mean the first
thing I think of just kind of stayed
with me for a long times the Turin Horse
of the militar film his last film I
remember seeing that at near Film
Festival a couple couple years ago in
the theater and yeah it was it was like
almost like a not religious but it was
almost like a holy weird experience that
no actually the the Julianne Moore film
still Alice that really that kind of
blew me away and frightened me and I
felt I don't know it really it really
frightened me
and me what made you feel that you could
both play these characters when you read
the script one thing for me being
friends with Josh you know and I had
known Josh for years before and it is
it's not completely autobiographical but
it is a personal story so you know to do
it to do it right I mean not just as an
actor but I was his friend you know I
kind of felt a certain responsibility
yeah I think knowing that Josh was there
made it and I thought there was a lot
that I I recognized in this woman do you
know what I mean I had lost my own
mother to cancer the same year that we
shot the film so that I had that but
also I I don't know there were just you
know often we when we see mothers in
movies they're sort of perfect they're
very often very two-dimensional and I
feel like I could I could relate to it
to all the parts of this mother do you
know what I mean the like intense mother
love and and you know desire to have her
child you know succeed in every way
possible but also you know all the all
the parts of you know motherhood like
being controlling not not knowing how
controlling would be okay or you know
not not you know taking off your boxing
gloves when you're dealing with your kid
particularly your grown kid and and and
telling them really what you think not
pulling your punches I was listening to
an interview with Sir Michael Caine and
he said that an actor's greatest asset
first thing is the eyes second is the
voice for the two of you in the film
because there were a lot of moments
where there was just things that were
unspoken how do you use your eyes first
to convey emotion especially the opening
scene where you're in the bar and we're
not really hearing that much dialogue
but we're feeling that something's not
right there yeah I mean that's kind of a
weird thing it's something that you try
not to be conscious of you know I tried
to be conscious too much of my body
movements you know it's kind of maybe
something that just
you hope just happens naturally and you
know if you're I guess if you're focused
on if you focused on the the important
task at hand right it works you're right
if you're focused on the result that's
the bad thing if you're focused at the
real task at hand and that's that's the
good thing and so and if if you believe
if you're trying your hardest to believe
in this fake scenario which is what it
is then hopefully if you trick your mind
well enough maybe hopefully that comes
across yeah I also think that certainly
we convey emotion through our eyes in
every way including crying but I think
maybe more important even is I think we
convey intelligence through our eyes do
you know what I mean when I when I watch
someone understand something I see it a
little bit in their body language but I
mostly see it in their eyes or when I
see someone worried about something or
trying to figure something out like it's
the eyes are the where you see the most
reaction do you know so III one of the
most important things I think on film
that's very different from onstage is as
human beings were thinking all the time
or calculating and were you know the
manoeuvring and planning and I think
that we see that somewhat in our body
language but mostly in in our eyes we
see we see the other person think and so
when you see an actor really thinking
on-screen you believe they're a real
person sorry I could go another hour
thank you both
you